als er sich zu seiner vernehmung auf
machte hat donald trump einen plan stufe
eins in einem statement erklärt er das
ganze verfahren einmal mehr zur
hexenjagd und liefert gleich ein video
mit wie die justizministerin des
bundesstaates new york 1 stimmung gegen
ihn machte
wir müssen uns auf donald trump ort
seine missetaten konzentrieren
rausfinden wo er geld gewaschen hat
alles hier new york und ihm und allen
zeigen dass niemand über dem gesetz
steht
stufe 2 bei der vernehmung in manhattan
beantwortet keine fragen beruft sich auf
sein zeugnisverweigerungsrecht
dabei hat er doch selbst früher einmal
als mitarbeiter seiner rivalin hillary
clinton die aussage verweigerten gesagt
das macht nur die mafia aber niemand der
unschuldig ist
wirklich mafiöse praktiken hatte trumps
eigener ex anwalt michael kohn einmal
beschrieben er habe sein konzerngeflecht
maßlos überbewertet um leichter an
kredite zu kommen das new yorker
verfahren ist nur eins von vielen
genüsslich liste cnn ein paar auf
insgesamt aber sind es 17 stück
auch der kongress will einsicht den
trans steuerunterlagen nehmen und der
untersuchungsausschuss zum sturm aufs
kapital prüft ob trump direkt daran
beteiligt war listen mit falschen
wahlmännern zu erstellen um diese geht
es auch in einem separaten
strafverfahren des justizministeriums
dessen chef erst kürzlich eine klare
ansage machte
wir werden jeden zur verantwortung
ziehen der versucht hat den legitimen
und rechtmäßigen übergang von einer
regierung zur nächsten zu behindern
dazu gehört eben auch die frage ob trump
geheime staatsdokumenten mitgehen ließ
doch der abgewählte präsident stellt die
fbi razzia als teil der hexenjagd da und
sich als opfer befeuert die empörung
seiner anhänger nur wenige republikaner
warnen vor kurzschlüssen
als amerikaner hoffe ich dass das
legitime ermittlungen sind dass es einen
ernsten hintergrund hat wenn nicht wäre
das ein großer fehler aber ich vermute
sie haben etwas was sie prüfen und dann
noch weiter vorantreiben werden
aber trumps umdeutung der
rechtsstaatlichen verfahren
radikalisiert seine anhänger immer mehr
fordern er solle wieder kandidieren
manche rufen sogar zu gewalt auf kein
wort von ihnen dazu für trump so scheint
es läuft alles soweit nach plan
und wir fragen noch mal nach bei unserem
usa korrespondenten elmar theveßen
schönen guten morgen trumps anhänger
haben wir gerade gesehen stehen nach wie
vor hinter ihm obwohl er die aussage vor
gericht verweigert und überhaupt
zahlreiche verfahren gegen jumpy
anlaufen wie gefährlich kann das ganze
jetzt dem ex-präsidenten werden
es kann gefährlich werden nach außen
versuchte er das ganze natürlich
herauszuzögern deswegen hat er über 400
mal auf die fragen dann von seinem
zeugnisverweigerungsrecht
dann auch gebrauch gemacht aber
amerikanische medien berichten unter
berufung aus quellen auf quellen aus dem
umfeld im unmittelbaren umfeld von
donald trump dass er doch ein großer
unruhe und sorge ist dass er vermutet
dass es einen maulwurf gibt in seinem
umfeld also jemand der informationen an
das fbi gegeben hat denn das fbi auguste
ganz offenbar sehr sehr genau welche
dokumente noch in marl lago in florida
lagerten und wo man sie finden würde und
deswegen raten einige freunde von donald
trump ihm auch er soll möglichst schnell
seine kandidatur als
präsidentschaftskandidat erklären weil
sie glauben dass er dadurch dann besser
vor strafverfolgung geschützt wird der
präsident neigt dazu hören wir und er
ist schon eifrig dabei eben spenden zu
sammeln zum beispiel per e-mail ich
selber ab heute dutzende von mails von
donald trump und seinen unterstützern
bekommen die um spenden baten in einer
hieß es ich sei der patriot des monats
und müsste dringend jetzt weiter spenden
und ich will mal eine zeigen die sie
hier wo donald schwarmbeben behauptet
dass dieser fbi razzien angriff auf ihn
durch die radikale linke gewesen sein
und unten drunter sind die knöpfe auf
die man klicken kann dass man dann 250
dollar oder auch ein bisschen weniger
spendet also er ist nach wie vor im
angriffsmodus aber ich glaube es wird
ernst für ihn
noch einmal kandidieren möchte seine
anhänger wollen das ja unterstützen wie
groß ist denn das risiko dass diese
anhänger sich dann auch jetzt noch mal
weiter radikalisieren
ja die gefahr ist gross und zwar wenn
man mal unterwegs ist in den sozialen
medien findet man dutzende von anhängern
die kleine videos posten auf denen sie
zum bürgerkrieg aufrufen zu den waffen
rufen dass sie waffengewalt androhen
wenn das fbi versuchen sollte dort fand
beispielsweise festzunehmen und ein
beispiel hat mich vorhin besonders
betroffen gemacht rx war wohl ein
demokratischer abgeordneter hat ein
audio
weitergegeben an die öffentlichkeit dass
er auf seinem handy vorgefunden hat eine
audiobotschaft in der er unmittelbar vor
allen dingen auch seine frau und seine
kinder mit dem tode bedroht werden der
fbi direktor hat jetzt gesagt das was da
passiert das sei schändlich und das sei
eben auch gefährlich ich glaube das ist
so und da wäre es eigentlich zeit ist
die republikanischen anführer sich dem
entgegenstellen aber die tun gerade
genau das gegenteil sie gießen öl ins
feuer ins feuer und unterstützen donald
trump in seiner opferrolle
live auf schenken vielen dank